aujourd'hui pour ce module sport nous
sommes à montillot bretonneux pour
découvrir l'haltérophilie nous sommes au
club sky haltéro
pour découvrir ce club aux côtés de
serre et le président du club alors quel
est l'historique de ce club alors ce
canal terreau était créée il ya quatre
ans maintenant en 2018 l'idée du club
d'haltérophilie vraiment de donner accès
aux loisirs aux compétitions de faire ce
sport qui est pour nous un excellent
pour la santé il a été créé en 2010 8,1
c'est bien ça 2018 c'est ça oui et du
coup combien d'adhérents au total au
total on a une cinquantaine d'adhérents
en comptant les ans les teens liquide et
les adultes donc réparti en 50 % ou
quasi 50 % de féminines lots restants
masculin et pourquoi avoir voulu créer
ce club ici alors on a depuis quelques
années le crossfit qui arrivait assez
fort ou l'haltérophilie fait partie
d'une des composantes du crossfit et
donc
à l'origine le président du club l'a
créée pour renforcer cette compétence
d'haltéro pure qui sert au cros suite et
on a remarqué qu'il y avait de plus en
plus de demandes pour faire deux
latéraux en spécifique et donc l'idée
c'est le pourra faire des compétitions
d'haltérophilie pur dans les yvelines
est d'autant plus à saint quentin en
yvelines où on est le seul club est ce
qu'il y à beaucoup de clubs dans les
yvelines d'haltérophilie alors à ma
connaissance non je crois que passent
aussi les connais je pense qu'on est
quatre clubs dans les yvelines mais si
je me trompe pas et qu'est ce qui fait
que ce sport est peut-être un peu
confidentiel je pense qu'on se rapproche
dans l'image du body building qui est
pas forcément toujours bien vu par le
grand public l'haltérophilie est très
éloignée ça vu qu'on a des bars
on se rapproche beaucoup de ces sports
bodybuilding power lifting et tout un
peu mélangés dans le grand public bien
que aux jeux olympiques on voit
l'haltérophilie qui est le seul sport
avec des barres qui est pratiqué oui
justement les jeux olympiques est ce que
ça vous aide à recruter des gens
je ne sais pas oui certainement en fait
on découvre beaucoup de gens découvrent
l'haltérophilie en regardant les jeux
olympiques et ensuite viennent essayer
mais comme je les dis beaucoup viennent
du croisic quand même à l'origine qui a
démocratisé beaucoup de sport et qu'est
ce que c'est concrètement
l'haltérophilie on les voit il soulève
beaucoup de poids derrière est ce que
c'est ça soulever des poids ou est-ce
que c'est plus complexe que ça alors la
base c'est soulever des poids mais après
c'est comment soulever des poids donc en
fait l'haltérophilie se décompose en
deux mouvements on à l'arraché on
dépasse la barre des mares du sol pour
être jusqu au dessus de la tête bras
tendus en un seul mouvement et on à
l'épaulé jeté ou une épaule la barre sur
les épaules puis on la met bras tendus
au-dessus de la tête donc ces deux
mouvements en compétition l'épaulé jeté
et l'a ratée qui sont importants après
dans un entraînement on va justement
face à optimiser ce mouvement-là travail
et des parties de mouvement ou la
totalité pour faire le plus de poids
possible il y a à peu près la moitié des
adhérents de votre club qui sont
compétiteurs aussi un objectif c'est
désormais en compétition effectivement
on a tous une partie loisirs
où ils vont certainement se renforcer
pour d'autres sports vous faire
l'haltéro pour le loisir par contre la
moitié compétition vont faire des
compétitions dédié à l'haltérophilie on
a un peu tous les niveaux on a des
débutants on va jusqu'en national donc
tout le monde et les bienvenus et
surtout on a un coach qui nous permet de
monter en niveau très rapidement et
efficacement on le voit depuis quatre
ans on a de plus en plus de la tête
compositeurs qui ont des niveaux de plus
en plus élevés l'objectif c'est de faire
peut-être de ce club l'un des meilleurs
en france en ile-de-france au monde si
possible mais d'être en tout cas de pour
l'instant vraiment l'objectif c'est de
démocratiser d'aller de plus en plus
loin au niveau de la compétition mais
voilà d'avoir de plus en plus
d'adhérents qui aiment ce sport et qui
découvrent ce sport c'est vraiment
important pour nous c'est le fait de
démocratiser l'haltérophile vous voulez
quand même remplir l'armoire à trophées
on commence bien on commence à remplir
l'armoire à trophées effectivement et
oui le but c'est de monter le plus le
plus haut possible dans les compétitions
et on le remarque derrière derrière moi
aussi ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
ya des filles et des garçons ont
l'habitude de dire que l'haltérophilie
c'est un sport de garçons finalement pas
du tout ici alors pas du tout ici on est
on est à peu près un tiers 2 féminine
voire un peu plus c'est un sport qui est
qui est très adapté à toutes les
morphologies et puisque ça demande
beaucoup de coordination de souplesse
alors on remarque souvent les féminines
ont ce cette capacité à vendre la
mobilité de la souplesse par rapport à
d'autres masculin quand il commence en
tout cas et donc c'est un sport qui qui
adapté à tous donc les fines gueules
aime beaucoup ce sport là pour pour ses
aspects souplesse mobilité explosivité
et forcément
[Applaudissements]
je suis donc maintenant aux côtés de
patrice le coach de la structure alors
patrice est ce que vous avez les
infrastructures pour pouvoir faire
progresser les sportifs qui sont arbres
tout à fait tout à fait nous avons un
club qui comprend il ya plusieurs bains
un matériel conséquent on peut donc
entraîner beaucoup de monde nous en
avons qu'est ce que c'est selon vous
l'haltérophile
l'haltérophilie c'est un sport
que l'on dit de force mais il faut
surtout être plutôt dynamique il faut
être coordonnée et avoir disons
une
une bonne
contre activité musculaire et ensuite la
puissance s'acquiert par le travail en
musculation est ce que c'est un sport
qui est vraiment accessible à tous alors
le sport est accessible à tout le monde
y compris au fil garçons évidemment on
voit d'ailleurs depuis des années que
les filles ont pris ça à bras le corps
et elles sont même étonnés de voir les
charges qu'ils peuvent mettre à bout de
bras et en fait où il est ouvert à tout
le monde et les meilleurs fille du coup
peuvent porter jusqu'à combien alors les
meilleures filles au niveau bac club a
bien sera de mon club un meilleur filles
c'est l'oreille elle pèse 64 kg lahrache
76 kg et à l'épaule et jette 87 aller
nationale et elle disputera la finale
des championnats de france en juin
prochain et chez les garçons alors chez
les garçons nous avons
plusieurs personnes qui sont d'un niveau
un peu inférieur ils sont fédéral ou
inter régionale et puis nous avons aussi
des départementaux et régionaux
qu'est-ce qu'il fait selon vous qu'un
sportif devient bonne haltérophiles
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il faut avoir surtout
une base de contractilité musculaire
parce que le sport haltérophiles est
explosif c'est un peu comme si vous
voulez d'un départ 200 m donc il faut
donc une comptabilité musculaire
adéquate et puis après il faut être
souple et coordonnée à partir de là
c'est un sport appartement où il avait
ses dispositions qui s'ouvre à tout le
monde quel que soit votre poids de corps
est ce qu'on les repère rapidement passé
sportif qui sont susceptibles de devenir
des bons haltérophiles tout à fait on
voit rapidement une souplesse
articulaire et on voit rapidement une
contre activité musculaire absolument
absolument oui ça va très vite à
décevoir garder on le voit sur la
coordination et les gestes le voici
maintenant la seule chose qui s'acquiert
vraiment en haltérophilie c'est la
puissance d'ailleurs une force vitesse
mais cette force vitesse ça va être
acquises par des mouvements de tirage de
squats donc les performances ce monde
toujours avec une sécurité puisque sans
acquérir cette puissance vous pouvez
augmenter vos charges dont vous voyez
c'est une discipline quand même qui
stabilisent l'athlète au départ et qui
lui permet de monter au front est-ce
qu'on peut progresser rapidement alors
progresser rapidement il ya donc deux
mouvements et un mouvement d'arracher et
d'épauler jeter le mouvement d'arracher
est très technique et réclame une
technique parfaite puisque vous devez
prendre la barre du soleil de l'amener
directement à bout de bras à une prise
de demain assez large pour pouvoir se
faire donc il faut être précis il faut
être technique mais oui on arrive à
progresser et l'épaulé-jeté et plus en
puissance quand même puisque vous avez
un temps d'épaulé et un temps de jeter
ces deux mots de gestes dans le même
mouvement mais oui on progresse
comprend bien si on a le geste on peut
vite progresser c'est à dire que oui
sans technique pouvait pas faire
d'haltérophilie et vous et surtout à
l'arraché même à l'épaule et le jeter ça
s'apprend donc séparément par des
tirages des squats et des goethe et
voilà on parle de semaines de mois
peut-être pour progresser deux semaines
et de mois oui ça dépend ça dépend en
fait de la personne dépend des
dispositions qui l'a naturellement
dernière question quel est votre plus
grand rêve à vous en tant que coach ici
ben mon plus grand rêve ce serait de les
amener en haut niveau international
maintenant nous avons une nationale
allait pas loin de la classe
internationale j'entraîne ici depuis
deux ans c'est donc ma troisième saison
et peut-être que elle pourrait peut-être
faire une carrière internationale
ce qui serait quand même très
intéressant mais même pour les autres il
évolue bien nous avons des filles de 59
kg qui commence déjà la petite l'avoir
mathilde la 59 kg elle arrache déjà 55
donc el harrach parce que son poids de
corps donc oui si
sympathique
[Musique]
à mégoter maintenant deux athlètes du
club deux athlètes qui ont commencé
l'haltérophilie à quelques quelques
semaines quelques mois quelques années
alors lorraine et nicolas vous êtes
apparemment les deux meilleurs sportifs
du club est ce que c'est vrai
c'est vrai modeste on se débrouille bien
oui on s'en sort et pourquoi vous avez
commencé du coup l'haltérophilie donc
moi j'ai découvert l'haltérophilie par
le crossfit est du coup passée via la
pratique du crossfit que j'ai
j'ai de plus en plus eu d'affinités avec
l'haltérophilie et donc du coup je me
suis dit pour améliorer ma technique est
améliorée mais perd ce de manière
générale en haltérophilie pour le
crossfit je vais m'inscrire dans une
salle d'haltérophilie alors nicolas pour
vous c'est un peu plus récent c'était il
ya seulement un an ouais en fait j'ai
commencé du coup l'haltéro là il ya un
an le crossfit depuis trois ans du coup
un peu comme un peu comme lauren par
rapport au cra suite le fait de
travailler plus la technique que la
l'intensité des mouvements je peux ça
plus intéressant est ce qui est
intéressant justement dans ce sport
qu'est ce qu'on travaille on travaille
différentes facettes de notre fitness on
travaille bien la force parce que là
l'haltérophilie c'est avant tout un
sport de force et on travaille aussi la
mobilité parce que si on n'est pas
mobile ben on va pas être bien placé
sous notre bar et du coup notre baron va
pas réussir à la remontée on travaille
aussi dans notre technique c'est mine de
rien l'arraché l'épaulé jeté son deux
mouvements qui sont très techniques
certes il faut être fort mais il faut
aussi assimilé le mouvement pour avoir
une position optimale à la fin et
réussir réussir notre barque et pourquoi
vous avez choisi ce club en particulier
ben moi c'était c'était là on va dire je
mets du crossfit ici donc du coup le
fait de devoir le coach
va entraîner les autres personnes ça m'a
donné envie de rester ici tout
simplement fait même chose lorraine
alors moi je fais pas le crossfit ici
mais je fais l'haltéro ici parce que bah
c'est l'association en fait la plus
proche je dirais pas là où j'habite donc
du coup ces niveaux localisation oui on
n'a pas beaucoup en ile de france même
dans les yvelines comment comment ça
s'explique c'est peut-être pas un sport
encore assez répandu est encore un sport
assez démocratiser oui c'est ça commence
à venir petit à petit on voit de plus en
plus d'adhérents surtout plus en plus de
femmes aussi avant il y avait vraiment
très peu de femmes et là il y en a de
plus en plus grâce au crossfit et mais
ça manque encore de démocratisation un
peu partout en fait en france et quand
on vous avait dit à votre entourage que
vous faisiez l'haltérophilie comment ils
ont réagi à moi c'est toujours les mêmes
messages l'attention attendent aux
attentions attendait mais sinon bah
comme choix du crossfit depuis trois ans
ça les a pas
pas trop choquer mais plus le cost et
pas attention aux blessures que quelque
chose est ce qu'on n'est pas encore dans
les clichés
ci encore encore si parce que en soit on
dit attention à ton dos mais d'un autre
côté d'haltérophilie c'est quand même un
sport où justement on renforce tout ce
qui est ceinture abdominale est
justement aussi le dos donc du coup les
haltérophiles c'est les personnes qui en
limitent le don le plus solide donc il
ya quand même enfin c'est assez je sais
pas comment dire c'est un cliché non
fondées en fait tant sur notre dos il
est très résistant faut pas s'inquiéter
et quels sont vos objectifs à tous les
deux dans cette discipline
nos objectifs bah moi personnellement
mon objectif c'est de
d'améliorer ma technique et d'encore
augmenter en en performance de soulever
plus lourd pour voir jusqu'où en fait
mon corps est capable d'aller pour me
challenge est toujours plus nicolas
aubin mois début c'était plus un loisir
là je vais tester la compétition la
début avril voir où je peux aller après
j'ai pas de grandes ambitions non plus
mais le contexte est donc comparé aux
autres un petit peu le président disait
qu'il fallait remplir l'armoire à
trophées est-ce que woods vous allez la
remplir on essaie on travaille pour
on verra ça un petit message pour ceux
peut-être qui veulent découvrir ce sport
allez-y tenter franchement c'est top
c'est un sport très ludique est vraiment
très intéressant à pratiquer
moi je le conseille j'ai adhéré dès la
première séance nicolas ier puis en plus
ici les gens sont sympas y ait une bonne
ambiance tout le monde se poussent donc
tout le monde s'encourage donc kaka c
est quoi
[Musique]
si vous voulez tester l'haltérophilie
ici à montigny le bretonneux ses 210
euros pour la compétition et 190 euros
pour le loisir venez tester
[Musique]
et